[Music]
now to the cover story of this week's
magazine
tick-tock intifada journalist james ball
is the author of the piece
arguing that social media is inflaming
international tension
in the israel-palestine conflict for
instance videos shared on tick tock
encourage violence and spread
disinformation
james joins me now with seth fransman a
middle east analyst and journalist based
in jerusalem
james in this week's cover piece you say
that tiktok and social media inflame
global conflict
the most recent example of this violence
is in israel and palestine
what role has it played there i think
for a while we've known that there's the
potential for social media to
inflame sort of ongoing tensions just
through making them really sorry
just through who making them more
visible
and sort of really evoking emotions
obviously if people can see
firsthand the aftermath of an attack um
or something like that it really gives
the immediacy
what we're seeing sort of move into it
that's a bit new and a bit
escalating is that sort of in the run-up
to the tensions that led to
the sort of latest bounce of conflict in
gaza
um was there seemed to be a tick-tock
trend around
um assaulting uh visibly jewish people
there was quite a viral video
of a man being assaulted by two
teenagers on public transport
and these sort of challenges against a
sort of already tense
backdrop seem to really uh
add fuel to the fire in country
and then what's happened as as the
conflict sort of broken out
is even people who don't seek out
anything on israel palestine who've
never
thought about the issue never engaged
with it suddenly see it in their tick
tock feeds in their twitter feeds on
facebook
and it really sort of escalates things
it makes it
harder for either side to back down even
if they wanted to
james why is tick-tock becoming the
popular place to share this
horrible kind of thing you can post
videos on twitter
facebook instagram so why is this the
platform
um it's difficult to sort of say i don't
think it is the only one i think this is
happening on every platform but
tick tock's the new one and the one that
has the youngest user base and so
it's often people's introduction to
politics
it also seems to be sort of
perhaps the most tilted in one direction
um you can sort of go quite quickly on
tick tock
on its discovery page from looking at
what you would usually do
and it's got lots of you know diet pill
type stuff
it's got inspirational baking it's got
makeup tutorials
and you can jump to that to then
suddenly a very jarring
sort of depiction of violence in in gaza
um just because of what's working on the
content and the strange rights algorithm
works
i think one thing that's become notable
on tick tock is
its jewish users now just cannot escape
the issue um in a way that's really kind
of not okay
people who have no connection to israel
have never lived in israel have never
sort of expressed support for the
actions of israel's government
and are doing a video about something
totally unrelated
we'll just find all of their reactions
and responses are free palestine
um just as we don't think it's
acceptable to hold say
a british muslim accountable for what
the state of saudi arabia does
um there really is problems inherent
in that kind of response and we are
seeing quite a lot of that on tech sock
seth you're in jerusalem can you give us
an update on what's happening right now
yeah i think there is an attempt now to
achieve a ceasefire between
israel and hamas but there has also been
so far i think on by day 11 a total of 4
000 rockets fired and
there was an attack on a bus this
morning a military bus near the gaza
strip by an anti-tank missile
then we've had sirens around the gaza
strip but i think up into ashkelon so
it does appear that you know hamas will
try to
continue firing rockets and achieve a
tax right up until whatever ceasefire is
broken
so that they can claim that they kind of
won and i think that's what we'll see
um there has been a relatively let's say
quiet eight or ten hours and i don't
think there's been a lot of airstrikes
by israel as well so
it remains to be seen if by friday the
conflict may
end seth what we're seeing on social
media is a growing but not necessarily
new phenomenon
can you talk to us about the history of
social media in middle east conflicts
i know it was used notably in the 2011
arab spring for example
yeah i mean i think that social media
certainly helped to transform the middle
east in terms of giving lots of people
um you know a decade a half ago a lot
more of a voice average people
i think though there was a change you
know after the arab spring in which you
also saw a lot of social media used by
isis
and extremists so that you know i
remember back in 2014 you know people
were just publishing
beheading videos and stuff it was people
were putting the most graphic content on
and they say that when twitter and
facebook went to remove
uh pro isis accounts you know they had
to remove millions of them so
there was a huge amount of extremist
content so actually
what was supposed to be a positive thing
for people to you know protest against
authoritarian regimes
actually became instead of something
that helps people or
achieves coexistence i would say that it
helped to radicalize large numbers of
people
and actually it enabled something like
50 000 people from around the world to
come
join isis because they were able usually
to coordinate initially on social media
and then they were able to use other
things like whatsapp or whatever but
they that's how many of them it seemed
to be able to actually physically were
able to come
so i think that is a very bad phenomenon
you could almost
argue that uh the explosion in the use
of social media helped to contribute to
the isis genocide and i think that
if you go back to the era of bin laden
remember he used to produce like tapes
and stuff that were
were prov handed out one to one you know
you can't radicalize as many people if
you're if you're distributing tapes
uh you can do it a lot faster if you're
using um you know a platform that gives
you access to millions of people so i
think that
unfortunately we've seen that social
media in a strange way
radicalized and made people more
sectarian and now of course you know the
big organizations or corporations that
run it have tried to then
you know i think in a kind of arbitrary
ham-handed manner
you know try to cut off little pieces
here and here like oh let's get rid of
isis accounts let's get rid of the
radical right that's fine
but there isn't a lot of systematic
thought put into it i think we
so we've come to a point now where even
states
in the region like turkey or other
places you know will try to
try to get the companies actually to
remove content that they don't agree
with
or they pass laws for instance that will
make it so you for instance can't post
certain things
if you're in certain countries you know
i think that is
unfortunately turning us into a bit of
an orwellian world so it's a
it's totally the opposite of what we
thought social media was going to be
doing
but that also is you know kind of the
onus i guess is on the average person
because
it's a hobbesian world people are not
necessarily good so
social media in some ways just catered
uh to the loudest worst voices because
we're just i mean we're generally used
to the fact that
the average normal nice person just
doesn't have a megaphone so i think that
that's something we saw a lot in the
middle east unfortunately
james can you talk us through the
psychology of posting these videos to
social media in the first place
you would think that posting such a
graphic horrible video to a platform
like tick tock would lose you support
not help you gain support
i think there's sometimes sort of the
the shock of the new people want to feel
engaged people might not want to watch a
traditional news show
but you know i think gen z gets quite
patronized if people suggest they're not
into news or they're only into
minor stuff and so part of it is a
desire to sort of show that you're
taking things seriously
but also the sort of key tone of a good
social post as well as kind of tucking
on emotions
is trying to sort of explain something
that the mainstream isn't telling you
now that can often be the full-on
conspiratorial q a
stuff that we tend to see on facebook
actually on youtube more than tick tock
but it can also be a hey but what
they're not telling you is this was
actually a colonial settle
settlement to do x y or zed and that
sort of
you know networked informal kind of
thing
sort of helps pull people in it helps
sort of build a community it helps get a
bit of
credo people like to feel knowing
and so it sort of does appeal to people
it's you know it's it's good cause it's
a good protest cause
um and sort of young adults in every
generation have always wanted those
um and of course it does attach to a
real
serious political movement um it's just
often the way
social introduces people to it can be
quite strange and it should be said
there is quite a lot of
outright misinformation um on both
on actually pro-israel and pro-palestine
accounts you know people re-using old
videos people kind of knowingly
misleading including some people tied to
ministries
so it's it's really a mess out there
seth finally um to follow on from
james's point
and point you were making before when
you were saying that actually in many
ways in the past social media has been
used as a
force for good um how do you weigh it up
now
with these kinds of videos going around
with the disinformation
do you think social media has been a
force for good when it comes to
political matters
um i don't know if it's necessarily a
force for good but i mean it's just it
is it's it's a force it's a medium right
i mean
i don't know if radio or tv or
necessarily or
print media have always been a force for
good i mean it's a nature of
it's the nature of a platform so i just
think
it exists i think that it can do good i
think when you have a conflict
you know you obviously tend to then
emphasize all the worst
attributes of things because obviously
you know the
the worst scenes of children being
killed or whatever you're going to be
posted even if they're fake but it
doesn't matter that's the kind of thing
that's going to be uh passed around
but i think look after the abraham
accords last year when there was peace
between israel and some of the gulf
states
you know social media played a huge role
i think in terms of amongst
a small group of people of posting you
know
stories about coexistence and hanukkah
and joined shared holidays so
you know it can also be a place that
lots of people meet i mean i think
that's one positive aspect so
when there is when there is a kind of
positive wind blowing of peace and
things like that
then you can see it definitely as a
force for good so i think it's just it
also just depends maybe on what
what kind of controversy or what kind of
you know political climate there is at
the time
thank you james and thank you seth
[Music]
you